Steve Almond has been a guest on my
program multiple times and I don't like
calling Steve a sports writer because he
writes about so many things but Steve
does sometimes write about sports Laura
Ingram on Fox News thought it would be a
good idea to bring Steve Almond on last
night to talk about what's going on with
Demar Hamlin who suffered a cardiac
arrest during the game on Monday night
we've talked about it already to some
degree
but this was a very very bad idea for
Laura Ingram he brings up
that Fox News has thrown money to settle
sexual assault claims in sort of making
an analogy to how the NFL will settle
brain injury stuff without actually
changing the underlying circumstances of
football that allow the brain injuries
to become common
everything about this interview is
absolutely fantastic and eventually
Laura Ingram just cuts it off when he
tries to bring up Laura Ingram's past
misdeeds when she taunted Parkland
shooting survivors
leading advertisers to flee her show
this is really good let's go to the
first clip putting monitors in helmets
to try to make sure that people aren't
suffering too many concussive or
sub-concussive events these are things
the NFL could do tomorrow but they're
not going to do it until there's an
economic incentive the reason they
settled that lawsuit is because they had
a PR problem it's like at Fox News when
you have you know hosts who are
allegedly sexually harassing people Fox
News throws money at that tonight that
PR problem go away that's what happens
in people well nobody nobody has done
more I mean you know that right you know
that yeah that's a cute little note but
I'm trying I love it you know every time
guests call out fox on Fox these hosts
have some line like oh that's cute
that's a cute move no he's showing up
and he's pointing out that that which
you are criticizing someone else for
your employer also does it's not about
being cute it's that they don't know how
to handle it when guests actually Point
these things out let's go to another
clip here they have enormous amount of
fans what happened during George
I mean they changed the whole corporate
approach to race and equity and and all
the things that happened two and a half
years ago so you say the players don't
have all that much influence I would say
the players have an enormous amount of
influence maybe not as much as they want
but there's there's huge economic upside
for everyone here correct
well I know you're focused on the
players I'm focused on the fans
and what I essentially believe is not
that any government ban is going to make
football safer and certainly not some
Mythic woke mob that you mentioned to
try to scare your viewers I think it's
going to happen I'm not trying to scare
the viewers football's not about
politics it's not about politics your
entire economic model your entire
economic models
I mean Steve you really why wait you
really want to change your behavior yeah
you want football to be bad I don't this
is what you do oh come on you you what
you you want football essentially
changed into I don't know what like I
don't know we have a sensor in the
helmet I guess okay propose one you know
is that is that technology troubling to
you no not in there if you're concerned
about the players
play in a way that is safer you're not
concerned about the play the thing about
people like Laura Ingram is Steve Almond
accurately points out
it's it is about scaring viewers it's
all about scaring viewers and when it
comes to football the way they see the
really scary thing about football and I
now have friends who have kids who are
sort of starting to get curious about
football and they're like oh my goodness
the last thing I want is my kid to play
football so they're trying to find a
balance between straight up saying you
were not allowed to play because then
that can cause this kind of reaction
where the kid goes well I really want to
play if I'm not allowed to play just
kind of finding the right way to
dissuade softly dissuade uh their kids
from wanting to play football the thing
about football is it is fundamentally
dangerous the brain injury stuff is
completely off the charts it's shocking
to me that football even still sort of
exists at the college level and I think
it's possible that if and when the
lawsuits start at the college level uh
it will really really damage the the
prospects of football I find it you know
mildly entertaining there's other sports
I like better but it just seems crazy
that it's still a thing Laura Ingram
and her model in the model of foxes
we've got to scare the audience we have
to scare the audience and and ideally
about what the left or or someone uh uh
external to our movement is doing
so with football it's they want to have
a nanny state where they ban a sport
or they want to over regulate football
by saying oh you've got to do this
you've got to do that you've got to
force players out concussion Protocols
are too strict or sensors in the helmet
it's all crazy or whatever it all has to
be fear fear fear they're going to take
it away and with football there's also
the patriotism angle which they love
which is there's something patriotic and
manly it's both patriotic and manly and
so any skepticism about football and and
football's viability is not only [ __ ]
it's also anti-American this is the
whole sort of narrative but when it like
comes right down to it Laura Ingram kind
of has no choice but to say no I mean I
guess I'd be fine with a sensor with a
sensor in the helmet that indicates you
know what were the what were the
g-forces was there a possible concussion
or whatever the case may be because
these are these are perfectly logical
things as half measures to really
dealing with football big picture now
this is not the hill I'm going to die on
I'm not going around looking to end
football it's shocking to me that
anybody lets their kids play football at
this point and I know let them you know
how what that that's a whole difficult
premise premise as well but this is how
these folks operate make everybody
afraid Steve Allman's completely right
when it comes down to it you go well
it's not so much that I'm opposed to
thing number one or two or three but we
should be very afraid of what they are
trying to do here's the last segment
during which Steve Allman points out
she had a problem with advertisers
fleeing for things she said and then she
just ends the interview so thrilling the
reason that people change their behavior
is because there's an economic incentive
a couple years ago when you talked like
a Survivor apartment mass shooting
um
nice try buddy I appreciate it it's cut
it is cut cut
um yeah so other guests have done this
stuff before and the reaction from the
hot Fox hosts is is very similar it's
cut it laugh it off and say it's an
ambush or it's cute or it's funny or
whatever the case may be standard Mo
they all seem to know how to do it but
very nicely done by Steve Almond and I
mean listen this is Steve Allman's
bailiwick right that to invite him and
think he's not going to do this is
really the thing that shows you don't
really know who who he is really nice
job we should have him back on the show
soon it's a new year many of us are
trying to make new positive changes
here's something really simple simple
that could be a game changer our sponsor
athletic greens every day I take a scoop
of ag1 I get 75 high quality vitamins
minerals and Whole Food sourced
ingredients to last me all day long this
way I just know my nutritional bases are
covered for the entire day it has
everything I want and that's important
to me rather than doing the individual
supplements and vitamins or whatever I
don't want to do any of that okay ag1 is
the simplest way to just get everything
I want for my nutritional Foundation
each day ag1 is also a great bang for
your buck you're going to end up
spending way more on all those bottles
of vitamins and supplements and minerals
so save some money make your life easier
just a scoop of ag1 I love the travel
packs which let me take ag1 wherever I
go I have the big pack of ag-1 at home
and when you go to athleticgreens.com
Pacman you'll get five free three travel
packs plus a free year supply of vitamin
D which I use during the winter the link
is down below